why
so T'Challa or Black Panther is
historically one of the most important
characters in the history of comic books
and the reason that I say this is
because he really kind of changed the
archetype for african-americans in comic
books as a whole and I would go as far
as to say that he stands alongside
characters such as Superman and
spider-man
but where Superman created the superhero
standard he was really kind of the model
for virtually all superheroes that would
come after him and spider-man brought
teenagers out of the realm of being
relegated to sidekicks Black Panther
introduced to us our first black
superhero with super powers and this is
something that had never been seen
before now for the sake of this video
we're really only going to be focusing
on Black Panther proper meaning that
we're going to focus on him very little
when he's part of the Avengers and we're
going to be spending more time focusing
on the jungle action series in addition
to the publication history between
volumes 1 & 4 and the events leading up
to the Avengers vs. x-men storyline so
Black Panther first appears in July of
1966 in a two-part story in the
Fantastic Four issues number 52 and 53
called the Black Panther and what we see
here is that an emissary of the Black
Panther has appeared to the Fantastic
Four at their home base of operations in
the Baxter building and lets them know
where informs them that his King his
chieftain has invited the Fantastic Four
to the kingdom of Wakanda and that if
they choose to accept a great hunt will
be offered in their honor
the Fantastic Four of course choose to
accept this invitation but are kind of
astounded to see that this individual is
in possession of a piece of technology
that allows him to communicate with this
chieftain halfway across the world as we
see the Fantastic Four arrive at the
kingdom of Wakanda they are again
surprised to see that instead of this
area being a lush jungle paradise that
it is a technological paradise that
there are all forms of technology
available here and that the technology
that does exist here
chili is either equal to or exceeds a
lot of the technology that exists in the
world at the time
ultimately we learned that the great
hunt that is supposed to take place in
honor of the Fantastic Four is actually
the chieftain of Wakanda the Black
Panther hunting the Fantastic Four we
see that over the course of issue number
52 that he is able to separate the
Fantastic Four and to feed each one
individually however we also see that a
friend of Johnny storms who was brought
along for the journey named Wyatt
Wingfoot is able to infiltrate part of
Wakanda and able to free Johnny Storm
with Johnny Storm being freed Johnny
Storm is able to free the remaining
members of the Fantastic Four and
together they were able to defeat the
Black Panther now what we see here is
that the Black Panther really reveals
why it was that he attacked the
Fantastic Four in the first place and
the reason is kind of a backstory to
Black Panther it gives us a little bit
of an explanation in terms of how he
became who he was and what we learned is
that the Black Panther is the son of the
previous Black Panther the chieftain of
Wakanda and I believe his name is Chuck
to Chaddha
shikaka I cannot pronounce that name for
the life of me it's very difficult to
pronounce but in any event a villain
named ulysses klaw who will actually
become one of the Masters of evil and
one of the individuals that worked
alongside Ultron later on in the
Avengers we see that ulysses klaw had
actually killed his father in addition
to various other members of Wakanda in
an attempt to gain access to the vast
vibranium stores that Wakanda possesses
we ultimately see that after the death
of two challahs father that child
himself picks up the mantle of black
panther and becomes the chieftain of the
Wakanda trod the Panther tribe in what
the Wakanda country we also see that the
reason for him attacking the Fantastic
Four was to also test their abilities
because he knew that at one point in
time or some point in the future that
claw would return to attempt to take the
vibranium stores by force now we
ultimately see that Klaw does return and
with the assistance of the Fantastic
Four Black Panther is able to thwart the
schemes of the Klaw
now it was the intention of T'Challa to
kill Klaw but mr. fantastic actually
stops him from doing this ultimately at
the end of the two-part series we see
that Black Panther has kind of come to
the realization that his powers his
abilities could be used for a more
global method of protection that is
simply he's really not needed simply in
what Honda and so we actually see him
leave and we will pick up with him in
issue number 52 of the Avengers so the
next time that we see Black Panther is
in May of 1968 and he first appears in
the Avengers issue number 52 and this
marks the first full-on appearance of
black panther in the Avengers as a
member of the Avengers team and as far
as I understand it he's part of the
Avengers team for about 98 issues or so
for a few years and as part of the
Avengers he's actually witnessed to a
multitude of various events and
adventures in addition to coming across
some of the most notable and some of the
lesser-known villains in Marvel Comics
we see that he is one of the original
members of the Avengers that comes into
contact with Ultron for the first time
we ultimately see that he leaves the
Avengers and ends up going back to what
Conda and we pick up with him again in
general action issue number five and in
a new issue of jungle action issue
number six
so after T'Challa leaves the Avengers we
pick up with him and jungle action and
jungle action is a series that runs
between issues number five and issues
number 24 between 1973 I believe July of
1973 and November of 1976 now it's
really kind of a misnomer we say issue
number five being him featured in Jungle
action because this was actually a
reprint of a previous Avengers story the
new issues of jungle action starring
Black Panther actually don't start until
issue number six and that premieres in
September of 1973 now the jungle action
stories are actually very important
regarding the publication history of
Marvel Comics and black panther and the
reason why is because this is the first
time that we actually see black panther
getting
his own storyline in addition the jungle
action stories are split up into a into
two main parts but the entire run of
black panther and jungle action is
referred to as the panthers rage
storyline and what we see in the first
part is that Black Panther has returned
to Wakanda after having been part of the
Avengers to find that and a villain
named kill monger has attempted to usurp
the throne of King from him ultimately
he is successful in finding it off in
part two we see that he has traveled
back to the United States to fight the
Ku Klux Klan now this is really kind of
important here because this is really
kind of a representation and comic books
of the black power struggle against
racist elements within the United States
following the jungle action series we
actually pick up with Black Panther and
vol 1 some of the most notable story
arcs involving the Black Panther in
Marvel Comics actually take place
between vol 1 in 1977 and the end of vol
4 in 2008 and what we see in vol 1 is
the return of Ulysses Klaw for the most
part he's really kind of the mainstay
villain or the most notable villain to
make an appearance in Black Panther vol
1 and he's really swiftly defeated by
Black Panther because this is really
kind of march the point in which Black
Panther is moving beyond your normal
garden-variety old-school villains like
the claw and moving more towards
involvement in larger events in the
Marvel Universe in volume 3 we actually
see that era kill monger returns to
defeat a black panther in ritual combat
and therefore take the role of both
Black Panther and the king of Wakanda
himself in addition we also see that
Erik kill monger consumes the herb
that's reserved for the royal family
line which grants them enhanced
abilities the abilities that Black
Panther himself has although we end up
seeing that because he's not part of the
royal family line he succumbs to the
effects of the herb and is presumed to
have been killed in addition in the
2006-2007 crossover event the Civil War
we see that he marries
Roman roar Ororo Munroe and that they
also also take stands against the
superhuman Registration Act alongside
Captain America but we also see in the
2008 event the Secret Invasion is that
these scrolls and the wakandan people
come to a technological standstill in
terms of their fighting and ultimately
reduce to using very old fashioned
weapons swords and spears and and
shields we also see that in the event
the man without fear that Matt Murdock
the character daredevil approaches Black
Panther and asked him to undertake the
role of daredevil in the Hell's Kitchen
New York for a temporary time while Matt
Murdock sort of comes to personal
understanding and deals with his own
moral philosophies we see that Black
Panther undertakes this role and when
Matt Murdock returns Black Panther
himself returns to Wakanda so the powers
of the Black Panther are really kind of
intriguing here they're really kind of
interesting and in truth they can be a
little bit confusing in terms of how he
gains his powers in the Marvel Comics if
you're not a consistent reader and even
myself have to go back from time to time
and reread Black Panther comics to
ensure that I've actually got it correct
in terms of how it is it he gains his
powers as I understand it the method in
which he gains his powers is actually
twofold one is him gaining his powers
and the other one is an augment to the
powers that he gains the inherent
abilities that are given to him once he
undertakes the mantle of Black Panther
or enhanced speed enhanced senses all
senses being enhanced enhanced agility
of pretty much putting him on par
physically with Captain America or even
Wolverine now the way that he gains
these abilities is by undertaking a rite
of passage and the rite of passage is
what grants him the ability to become
the Black Panther he can't simply put on
a mask and become the Black Panther I
guess arguably he could but he wouldn't
necessarily have the abilities the
Panther God of the wakandan people has
to recognize a person as being the Black
Panther and once that happens the
abilities of the Black Panther are
bestowed on them now the powers that are
given to him are actually augmented by a
special heart shape
herb now whether or not he takes the
herb first or some necessary to take the
herb first and then become the black
panther I'm not entirely sure I would go
as far as to say that it's not really
necessary as we saw with kill monger
only members of the Royal line are able
to consume the heart-shaped herb without
succumbing to the effects and near death
ultimately we see that with white
panther having the senses that he does
he is very particular in terms of his
role in the Marvel Universe with him
having acute senses he is able to
memorize a multitude of individual
scents over the course of his lifetime
and never forgets those so let's say for
example in Marvel Comics he actually
deduces the identity of Matt Murdock as
daredevil and the way he does this is of
course he meets Matt Murdock and gains
the scent of Matt Murdock after
encountering daredevil the scent is the
same therefore to him they are both the
same person of course he's right in
terms of this deductive logic in
addition to the powers of Black Panther
has he is a prodigious martial artist he
is a master and various forms of world
renowned martial arts in addition to
unknown forms of martial arts that are
restricted to Africa on top of this due
to the advanced technology available to
him as the chieftain of Wakanda he has a
multitude of technological devices at
his at his expense I guess or at his at
his use and he uses these devices for a
multitude of different effects depending
on what the circumstances are depending
on the writer he may use something like
an energy dagger or it may simply be he
will use his suit which is composed of
vibranium to the full extent but really
use nothing else aside from his physical
attributes overall the powers that he
has and the abilities that he has make
him a very pivotal character both in his
own solo series in addition to being
part of the Avengers as well as taking
over the role of daredevil and Marvel
Comics once Matt Murdock leaves
so as I understand it Marvel has
confirmed that there will be a black
panther film that will take place
sometime after ant-man's release in
Phase three of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but as I understand that there
have currently not been any casting
calls for individuals to play the role
of Black Panther although I could be
wrong on this however in my mind there's
really only one person who is suitable
to play the role of Black Panther in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and that
person is of course Michael Jai White
now a lot of people are unfamiliar with
who Michael Jai White is but to me he is
really the only person capable of
pulling off the character of Black
Panther for several reasons one one of
Black Panthers most notable attributes
is the fact that he is a prodigious
martial artist and Michael Jai White
himself falls into this category
to my knowledge Michael Jai White holds
black belts and eight different martial
arts and has been studying martial arts
for about twenty years in addition to
this he has a great physical physique
and of course he's african-american and
so for these reasons I really couldn't
see anybody else playing the role now in
terms of Michael Jai White's filmography
his film history he's really kind of
been relegated to a lot of beamed be
rated films direct-to-dvd films blood
and bone movies like that of course I
first saw him and Universal Soldier the
return but of course that wasn't a
critically successful film but I really
think a lot of this is due to the fact
that he's kind of pigeon-holed in terms
of is a of his film appearances because
a lot of individuals that you see in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are either
very well-known actors or actors that
have appeared in some critically
successful films but weren't necessarily
huge Hollywood blockbuster actors I
think that with Michael Jai White this
is an instance of a guy who if given a
chance to really kind of demonstrate his
acting prowess that he would surprise
quite a few people and I really think
that he would be a fantastic choice to
play the character of T'Challa or Mike
or Black Panther in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with that being said I'm going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace